this week we're going to take a look at
exactly what you do with the photographs
after you've made them and once again
frankly we could devote a full six week
course to just this idea alone
presenting your work but we'll try to
cover this topic as best as we can in
just a couple of tutorials for you this
week so let's start with a few figures
just to dissect them and get you to
think more about how you create figures
with your images let's first take a look
at a figure that the researchers made
for a grand submission and here we see a
host of the pieces of devices and the
full devices all labeled they wanted to
show what they were capable of creating
of course which is quite important but
there's so much going on the question is
whether we want to bother looking
anywhere by the way just a note I didn't
make any of these images of the research
but I knew that a few of the original
images were in color so first of all why
not use the color renditions if you have
them now let's concentrate on the
composition of the figure why not
somehow find a way that makes some sort
of compositional sense so here we
reordered all of these devices according
to scale so we're giving the readers
some idea of how to look at this very
busy figure in addition we removed most
of the labeling and we created a key to
the images and that key would be labeled
with letters so that if you wanted more
information about this particular image
within the figure for example its scale
like this one you would then find that
letter in the caption and get more
information so you might not agree i
hope you do but if you look at them
side-by-side I hope you see that once
again by simplifying editing down your
figures to the essential pieces and
organize them to tell your story that
the reader and in this case the grand
reviewer enjoys looking at your figure
and understands the contents of your
figure if you're you
using up space in your article your
presentation or your grant submission
why not use that space so that the
viewers actually want to look in this
example you are seeing two photographs
that I made quite a while ago depicting
two ends of a long device the device was
too long to get into one frame so the
researchers use these two photographs in
one figure the left and the right side
of the device are combined indicating
that it's much longer as you can see
with this notation and we see all sorts
of labels and arrows and SEM inserts
what I suggested first from the very
beginning is please give us a little
more space to breathe so many figures
are packed so tightly with stuff and we
actually don't know how to even start
looking at it so for example adding
space around the perimeter is what I did
here by inserting the whole figure into
the area with a larger Candis sighs and
then I questioned the labeling if you
are labeling within an image it's
imperative to simplify or labeling and
clean it up and make it nice and neat
and here's what I mean by that try to
put all of your labels lined up as best
as you can either vertically and or
horizontally and next question whether
you really have to use a combination of
upper and lower case letters why not
make all of your labels lowercase get
rid of your arrows arrows with
arrowheads are completely unnecessary
they are distractions as labels lines
without the arrowheads are much better
to use they've just more refined rethink
your colors how about using blue instead
of fuchsia please so I hope you agree
that this is a cleaner way of labeling
your figures and in the end I also
questioned the need for the SEM inserts
I'm not sure we really see more
information about the structure of the
device with these additional as
EMS the optical image says all that we
want to say and so I would have deleted
the SMS but if you insist on including
inserts maybe because you just wanted to
show that you are capable of making them
which is fine at the very least orient
the inserts in the way the rest of the
optical image is oriented here we're
rotating these sem inserts 90 degrees to
make them more relevant to the full
image and now let's look at them
side-by-side once again I hope that you
agree that the redo is a much cleaner
and simplified figure which makes it
more accessible let's look at another
figure this photograph up here made by
the researcher shows the device and here
you see another point of view of that
same device down here we have a CAD
drawing to represent an important part
of the device where e coli are
travelling from one chamber to another
and this other final piece of the figure
is a micrograph of that very same
important connection between the two
chambers the question is number one are
these photographs more than good enough
I know that we talked about this a lot
but it's really important to think about
it it's pretty clear when you put a
photograph in your figure it's important
to have the best photograph you can make
I wasn't convinced that these images
were the best they could be and so I
offered to make another representation
of the device and so here this is the
image that I made which I hope you agree
looks better so we decided to replace
the first picture in the graphic the
next question is something I feel pretty
important to consider in this next
photograph ask ourselves are we really
giving more information or frankly is it
just redundant and so we collaboratively
decided that it's not an important piece
in the figure it's not saying anything
that we are not already saying so we
deleted it we're simplifying we're
editing down the figure 2
essential pieces after I looked at other
images that they made in the lab I
suggested that we include a fluorescing
image from their files of e.coli going
from one chamber to the next to sort of
match the lower right sem of the same
area and they agreed and what I also
suggested was to invert the fluorescing
image so that it would work well with
the rest of the pieces after all
remember fluorescence in this situation
is basically a tagging technique telling
us of evidence of the presence of a
particular structure in this case e coli
we're not measuring or quantifying
fluorescence and we'll talk about that
later when we discuss image manipulation
so in this case it's perfectly fine to
reverse the grayscale in the image
making this piece easier to read so we
replace the image we deleted with this
fluorescing image the researchers then
they decided they preferred another CAD
drawing to replace the first one which
is fine and finally we aligned and
resized all the images to give us equal
framing so we finally came up with what
we believed was a clearer figure less
redundant and it worked quite well as
you could see in the published paper so
we should compare them side-by-side and
once again I hope you see that the
second one is a market improvement this
is what we do on campus we work together
in groups to dissect all sorts of draft
submission it really works very well and
I encourage you to do the same on your
own campuses here's another figure that
another group of researchers put
together the tin sulfide powder which
yields some information then becomes
deposited and we see that somehow in an
SEM of that layer and ultimately the
idea is to show how the researchers
fabricated the solar cell it is about
process so we went through a whole
series of iterations and questions I've
added them down here so you could see a
number of the attempts by the
researchers
so when I came into the picture I first
questioned whether the graph really had
to be included in the figure perhaps it
could have been placed elsewhere in the
article and then we discussed whether it
was important to show the powder they
asked that I come up with another way of
portraying the tin sulfide powder I
tried it in vials I then suggested
putting the SEM within an illustration
showing the various layers and then I
made another photograph of the solar
cell which i think is better from their
rendition I hope you agree and we
eventually evolved this final figure
into this we concentrated on the picture
of the solar cell did not need the vials
of powder just showing the layers of the
material much easier for the reader to
see and understand what is going on in
this figure again editing and
simplifying